[Musique]
un matin de semaine un matin normal
darina se prépare à déjeuner une routine
réconfortante il y à peine cinq semaines
darina et sa soeur tremblay au son des
bandas kiev
darina est fébrile ce matin elle espère
ne rien oublier elle se rend à l'école
où elle a intégré une classe d'accueil
des racines et à seulement 13 ans darina
s'engouffre dans l'autobus en espérant
oublier
oublier cette guerre qui a provoqué
l'éclatement de sa famille le 24 février
à 5 heures du matin et hors de ma portée
nous échouons à mâcon
quand je suis allé sur le balcon par la
cuisine j'ai vu des gens qui sortaient
de la maison il courait avec des choses
dans leur voiture sont partis rapidement
ça me fait peur
pendant cette nuit elles vivent dans le
sous-sol de l'hôpital où leur mère
travaille elles dorment sur des lits de
fortune y joue avec ce qui leur tombe
sous la main elles attendent le signal
pour partir au canada en famille mais
leur mère médecin à kiev est forcé de
rester en ukraine tout comme leurs pères
conscrits au moment du départ elles
apprennent qu'elles feront la route avec
des inconnus pro domo cordon d'euros le
passage à la france aura été long
faisait froid il y avait beaucoup de
gens avaient beaucoup de petits enfants
tous m'ont été triste il avait pas ces
darina qui a pris ces images à la
frontière de la pologne elle est frappé
par la présence des enfants
quand on chante et on s'est vraiment
difficile je pense que tu es juste 13
ans mais tu as déjà des grandes
responsabilités pour ta vie et pour la
vita st
elles prennent ensuite l'avion varsovie
vers paris paris montréal elles sont
confuses fatigué et triste on nous dit
prost heureusement parfois te comprends
pas que journée quelle heure il est soit
quarante et une nouvelle sans arrêt sous
voie des bonnes choses et les choses qui
sont pas si bonnes c'est juste 13h avoir
comme réalité une réalité qui prendra du
temps à s'effacer
les filles sont maintenant en sécurité
chez leur tante qui les accueillent à
bras ouverts vous êtes à présent
ouvertement les enfants de le plan
c'est
cynique commence
davy qui recommence sous l'oeil
bienveillant d'isabelle depuis d'arena
dans la classe c'est particulier de me
lever le matin lire le journal et m'a
demandé qu'est ce qui t'arrive quelque
chose de vraiment dramatique qui vont
avoir un impact important sur la vie de
mon élève à l'aide de google barinas
communique avec ses camarades de classe
mais le défi est titanesque
[Applaudissements]
mais pas autant que celui de mettre fin
à la guerre darina et sa soeur
manifestent toutes les fins de semaine
ils sont des centaines à exiger des
actions plus radicales envers la russie
darina et sa soeur ignore combien de
temps ils resteront au canada elles
attendent la fin de cette invasion
pour que le téléphone cesse d'être le
seul lien qui les unit à leur mère ici
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal